chile lucha por controlar las llamas Con
vientos moderados y temperaturas por
encima de los 40 grados centígrados el
sur del país se ha visto afectado por
más de 250 incendios activos de los
cuales 80 están fuera de control según
informó el servicio nacional de
prevención y atención de desastres y
ahora ya me dijo que había que esperar
hasta el final para poder salvar la
casita que ustedes ven acá
y el taller y todas las cosas los
animales Así que esperamos Hasta el
final pero el hecho de esperar hasta el
final nos tocó la los pasos a la cuenta
y
lo encerró el juego el fuego afecta
especialmente a tres regiones del país
la araucanía bío bío y ñuble que se
encuentran bajo estado de catástrofe lo
que permite movilizar recursos y la
mayor participación de las fuerzas
armadas esta zona del país se
caracteriza por tener poca población una
gran extensión de bosques y una gran
riqueza agrícola según las autoridades
al menos 270.000 hectáreas han sido
consumidas por las llamas y las causas
aún son desconocidas Pero hay al menos
10 detenidos por su posible vinculación
a los incendios cabe la menor duda que
estos incendios son intencionales yo
tengo 53 años y de toda mi vida he
encontrado botellas en el campo vidrio
que muchas veces han dicho que no que
son iniciados por un espejo que Porque
trabajas con una motosierra eso es
mentira acá esto hay una intencionalidad
claramente
y obviamente ahí no hay nada que hacer
nosotros como vecinos solamente
Esperamos que llegue el fuego nomás el
presidente francés Emmanuel macron
también ofreció ayuda a Chile para
combatir el fuego mientras que México
Colombia Estados Unidos Ecuador Brasil y
Perú entre otros países de la región
también desplegaron asistencia